[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
episode of the week's best anime videos
which is a weekly anime newscast on our
channel the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments and
yes I am still trying out different
anime hairstyles deal with it and for
our first piece of news this week
there's been a lot of confusion lately
about Tokyo ghoul season 3 after
comicbook.com reported that a season 3
might be coming out sometime this year
so basically what happened is that a
senior director and viz media said in a
recent interview then one punch man
season 2 and Tokyo ghoul season 3 would
all be coming out sometime in 2017 which
created a huge uproar among Tokyo ghoul
fans who couldn't believe what they were
hearing however the fans hopes were
quickly crushed because the anime news
network is now reporting that those
rumors about a Tokyo ghoul season 3 were
false from what we are hearing right now
the senior director misspoke and what he
meant to say was that one punch man
season 2 and my hero academia season 2
will be coming out in 2017 and not Tokyo
ghoul season 3 so unfortunately for the
fans of Tokyo ghoul there is no new
information right now about a season 3
but if you're a big Tokyo ghoul fan and
you need something to help you get
through this whole thing a few days ago
the ister uploaded his acoustic piano
cover of the Tokyo ghoul opening unravel
so yeah be sure to check it out and then
you know cry yourself to sleep or
whatever
in other news my big epic roast before
this epic roast begins of that anime
snobs book is going to be taking place
on March 16th Thursday March 16th at 5
p.m. Eastern Standard Time at the
regular time that we hold our live
streams called ran cafe here on this
channel every week this is going to be a
special episode of ran cafe where we're
going to be roasting or critically
assessing that anime snobs novel and
helping me with this are going to be
Briggs from all-day anime and cyanide
blizzard we might even get one or two
additional guests on the stream we're
not sure yet but be sure to mark the
date that's March 16th Thursday at 5
p.m. Eastern Standard Time it's going to
be fun team four star has recently been
uploading short skits in which
characters from various different anime
show up to challenge sell to a battle
right before to sell games this week
sells challengers were jenos and Saitama
from one punch man and it was a
hilarious skit if a little bit
anticlimactic but I definitely recommend
checking this one out and speaking of
one punch man there have been a ton of
rumors going around in online media in
particular about one punch man season 2
and when it will actually be coming out
because there's been so much confusion
I've been getting a lot of questions
from you guys about this I decided to
make a one-punch man season 2 update
video where I'm going to be talking
about everything we know so far
about one punch man season 2 in this
video I'm going to take all of the
confirmed news as well as all the
credible rumors about one punch man
season two and put them in one place so
look out for that sometime tomorrow and
speaking of my videos this past Saturday
I uploaded a video about the best thing
in Mobile Suit Gundam iron blooded
orphans in my opinion I'm really proud
of how this one turned out so if you
like Mobile Suit Gundam and our blooded
orphans in particular be sure to check
it out the link is in the description
this week
crunchyroll released some of the voting
statistics for their 2016 anime awards
and they are boasting that over 1.8
million people voted in these awards now
again it is not a secret that I have a
big problem with these
Ward's for one thing we know we know
that people voted multiple times for
another if you actually look at the
breakdown by country of the people who
voted in these awards you will see that
over half of the votes came from the
United States with Canada and the UK
following in second and third place and
I don't know about you but this graph is
definitely not representative of the
global anime community in my opinion for
example the anime community in Latin
American countries is massive but they
are clearly not fairly represented here
and don't even get me started on Asian
countries outside of Japan of course
such as Korea China and the Philippines
which have a huge huge anime following
and they're clearly not represented in
this poll Seoul though crunchyroll is
already saying see you at the 2017
crunchyroll Awards I'm thinking how
about no crunchyroll how about we here
on this channel with the help of our
friends at Rand cafe organize our own
awards where we try to actually
represent quality in anime and where we
try to get everyone from around the
world engaged get all you guys engaged
in the award process this is something
that I've been thinking about for a
while so if you think that here an anime
uproar we should organize our own rant
cafe anime Awards for next year let me
know and maybe we can make it happen and
my favorite AMV for this week was a boku
no hero academia amv called in the end
by kiran AMD's there is a ton of
excitement right now about boku no hero
academia season 2 which premieres on
April 1st so in honor of that occasion I
decided to feature this MV definitely
check it out and that is it for this
week guys if you enjoyed these videos be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and let me
know down in the comments what crazy
thing I should do with my hair next and
until next time SIA space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]